yes an insight on where to go bring the
future into the present and then ability
to motivate people to to really get it
and a real appreciation of symbols and
that is a tremendous gift if I could
just tell you one story when I think of
Nelson Mandela there's about 20 episodes
in his mind and life that I really now
think about but the one that really got
me was when Mandela was first in office
are just released i didn't even know for
his president I think he's president
then but anyway the Afrikaner Afrikaans
who really did resist very much and it
was FW de Klerk really inspired them and
move them along but they were still not
comfortable with a black leader of south
africa which I'd never thought would
happen anyway they were the worst of the
apartheid supporters were all rugby
players and rugby fans and there was a
rugby tournament that ended up in South
Africa by chance oh this is my chance
pitino unless you believe in some divine
plan out there and so the stadium
basically had a hundred thousand
screaming african Effra connors they're
going for cheering for the south african
rugby team and they were playing Germany
or France or somebody like that in
Johannesburg and I'm sure there wasn't
three blacks in the crowd of a hundred
thousand if so they were just selling
good sessions or something like that
anyway Nelson Mandela shows up that day
goes in the locker room ahead of time
says come on you know I hope you win
this everything he says can I wear one
of your uniforms puts on the uniform of
the
of the rugby team goes out screams as
the lungs out for that is asked
afterwards you know how could you he
says these are our boys these are our
brothers these are after that time and
he said that at the time after that time
they won the match the leading team all
these I'm sure they were all racial
sorry I shouldn't say that but I mean
they were certainly for the white regime
there they took mandela put him on a
shoulder took him around and everybody
was not only shouting for the rugby
victory with the whole stadium 110,000
people shouting man bella ban bella this
was the symbolic move that said we're
all South Africans these are my boys and
I want my boys to win out there now
that's that's a beautiful story that is
an exceptional leader you know I'm sure
that when mandela says i want to go see
the rugby match today you know his whole
staff said oh you don't see the rugby
match I mean those aren't I our people
he's in or those are my people